Nick show us your Tiger Eyes me yeah
oh
[Music]
damn so there's this guy um his name's
coach Jesse okay this guy's a dating
expert oh this give me some tips are
going to uh we're going to review some
of his
advice um that kind of a is he a dating
Guru expert oh he's an expert can I say
something can I say something this is
just this is just off the top when I
hear someone that says they're a dating
expert I immediately want to be like no
you're not in my head oh okay this guy
might change your mind not everyone's
Suave like you Nick no I'm not even
saying that not everyone's like one for
one all you to do is you got with the
not everyone finds the love of their
life in high school Nick I never
realized he's a guru yeah he is so this
is him the first thing we're going to
look up is his his explanation called do
this to make your female friend horny oh
I'm in I'm in dude all right all right
this the kind of expert thing to make
your female friend horny for you as soon
as your female friend's on you you
should start punching through that wall
to building sexual tension that exactly
what bad boys do they break the rules
and they get to sexual tension fast Bad
Boys reach right into the heart of the
girl start dialing that sexual tension
knob up one out of 10 three out of 10
turning up the Heat giving her those
tingles and kicking that friendto friend
conversation right out the door way you
do that with a female friend is by
giving her the Tiger Eyes by slowing
down your speaking Rhythm and by
incidentally touching her all in unison
in combination to build sexual tension
and with enough of that stop trying to
build sexual tension horny for you get
too horny man you know what I don't wait
no how this is totally a bit this is not
real that's not real that's not real
tiger R come on real I don't I don't
it's a 100% real selling a course
there's no way it's real I don't like I
don't I don't like how we have to get
the program I don't like how a gay guy
is trying to tell straight men a gay guy
yeah I don't think it's right that a gay
man is trying to trying to tell straight
guys how to talk to women that's not
right on his website he said he's been
with hundreds of women oh he's straight
damn it yeah dude pull up pull up the
video with his shirt that guy has a bad
shirt one of us buys a program and then
we all share we share the password pull
up the video with what use J company
card whatever any video of him talking
you look at the shirt that he's wearing
I'm like that guy doesn't get [__] dud
I feel the experience though you don't
think a guy with this shirt gets [__]
the
[__] he's got the Lumberjack look he's
sexy that better than the last one or
your skinny is 20 lbs of extra weight
you're carrying around the Middle look
you're never going to compete eat with
that 20-year-old kid on those things
that's what I was thinking just give up
gentlemen if
youen you have to become the best
looking man you can be and that's how
you are dressed dressed it ain't about
working out oh it ain't about the extra
20 lbs on your [__] belly he's just
giving you the worst generic advice his
specialization is that he uh he helps
older men get younger women how come he
only has three lik on that video so sad
he only he only has um yeah he only has
followers there's so much I find the
gems baby there's so much production
value in his page his name his name is
yeah so under here it says I help older
guys to meet 20 to 30 new girls in just
6 weeks take the best two or three as
your
girlfriends damn those are his bullets
okay maybe he is serious his name attra
dude that's those are good results if he
could produce that with his 183
followers he does not look like his
profile pick what the [__] wait how how
old are we talking about is he like you
might be 50 with big ass man titties but
I'll make sure you get a hot ass girl in
her 20s he's like just wear shirts that
fit you like sick advice my boy Tak two
weeks sick advice takes two weeks he's
like when girls are talking look into
their eyes and touch them talk like a
tiger yeah bro like what the [__] you
know so what do you think about that
advice the Tiger Eyes so the Tiger Eyes
if you ask any girl mhm they'll tell you
because they've been chased their whole
life especially in entertainment YouTube
whatever when they go to meetings they
could sense when a dude wants to [__]
right away and the Tiger Eyes is [__]
creeper eyes yeah they all know they go
okay so this is this is the type of they
can immediately go Oh this is the dude
that is always down to explore to see if
[__] is available a like they can
they can sense it yeah Nick show us your
Tiger Eyes me yeah
oh damn I got a buddy right eye of the
tiger right there I got a buddy who was
who who met his he got with his chick
from like talking to each other online
right at first then they actually meet
and they're actually exactly who they
say they were right so but then he
immediately turns on this like Rico
Suave [__] Tiger Eyes like [__]
slow talk [__] and dude we out we were
on a double date me and Nikki and these
two and like she was like busting a gut
laughing about what a [__] loser he
was like the first time she met him and
how she was like ready to like Le and he
didn't even know well she had to like
basically stop him and be like why are
you talking to me like this like this is
not who you are I've talked to you
before on the phone why are you like in
person
like yeah yeah yeah [__] John B dude
sick though cuz to reach into her heart
and to turn up the dial I like that
you're saying that because I think
that's that's what's in this next thing
would you guys like to know how to make
anything sound
sexy I need it teach me he's going to
can I guess he's going to talk quieter
and slower sound sexy to a woman when
you speak to a girl simply slow down
[Laughter]
the how did you know pour the O into
water that
after and make sure you [__] rub your
hands like this too Al a little bit of
milk myself this delicious oatmeal that
I put into my mouth and I eat it
straight away not very sexy
sounding slow down pauses make it sexy
all right yeah I take the oats I pour
some oats into water and after 5 minutes
I put in some applesauce [__] I I'm
coming bro some sliced almonds and now
I've got myself a delicious oatmeal that
I put into my mouth sounds like he's
using too many Comas right away that
sounds like a boring math teacher for
real when I talk like that people fall
asleep sound sexy we have to hunt this
guy hey hey hey hey hey hey that post at
five likes all
right we have to hunt him down and
remove him from the earth yeah cuz we
don't want to give him giv all the
secrets this is all the locked Secrets
this is like this is like if we were all
magicians and we were pissed off that
one dude who went on live TV with the
mask and was just giv all the way the
[__] secrets I like this guy he's
giving away player Secrets now that
you've heard probably I could guess
every [__] that's two of the biggest
tips possible okay good good read this
one to yourself and tell me if you think
we should share this no
way are you [__] with me dude did you
hire this guy I know he hired this guy
and [__] put all this [__] up himself
how this thing there's no way this got
there's no way Ryan found him on Ferber
dude has almost 2,000 views man how okay
this is called are you kidding me how
does sneak touch a girl's boobs
parenthesis when you barely know her
shut up yes bro okay can I guess can I I
need to know can I guess what I need to
know it's as you're talking you slightly
lean in and E you've done
it this morning baby let me practice and
in today's video I'll be showing you how
to covertly sneak a girl that's
assault this got to be fake women with
the busty eye the [__] up you put that
on
you don't call him big bouncing jugs I
[__] can I subscribe if you're like
hey can I touch a here that's creepy for
sure so absolutely don't do that don't
do that good start to sneak touch a
girl's boots getting mad or slapping you
across the face yeah you don't want that
to happen three ways I personally used
myself touch a girl boobs
I've met just minutes before now the
third method I use to do this that's the
most outrageous of the three it's like
the funniest of the three we got to be
careful with this one so funny guys how
to [__] grope women covertly catch it
now of course if you want to be a
complete gentleman and play it safe then
this video is not for you get the [__]
out of here dude the be rolls the guys
looking into the
ocean first way I've done it where I've
sneak touched a girl boobs is when
you're talking to a woman and she's
engaged in the conversation with you
simp she might say oh I like to read
books and you might tell her I like to
read books you like to read books you
are such a dor and you're just going to
push her shut the [__]
very you're such a dork you're such a
dork
dude oh my God this just isn't going to
work out girl red is obviously the
Superior Color I am so divorcing you and
you reach out and you give her a playful
teasing nudge brushing up against her
boot shut the [__] up this is not real
dude r h this
gu this is a [__]
scpt you way you bought him on fiber got
on F he upload all you got this actor to
write read a script he's been coaching
men for over 20 years shut the [__] up
Ryan's always been the long con he hired
him 20 years ago the signs that she's
easy I got to know wait you hired him
when you're at UCI wait wait wait I want
to know more about I want to know how to
touch a woman's boob a you want to know
about that but what's number three the
outrageous one what's the outrageous
this is some weird Ryan and smack bit
they hired this [__] guy that's smack
brother yeah yeah yeah got a GRE [__]
can't be real cross her face you want
you really want to see what the
thir direct for research
making a bold move no I don't like the
Bold move with Bart dude imagine you're
talking to a girl at a bar you look down
at her breasts you gesture wow you got
some beautiful acids there you take her
by the hands you pull her in you give
her a little yank come here girl you
give her a little yank made two bold
moves right there so you need to
calibrate to this particular that point
is she into the Bold moves or is she not
into the Bold moves how is she resp
responding do you see the excitement
light up in her eyes do you see that
smile go across her face and some girls
some girls they really go wild that
archetype of an attractive man that just
goes for what he wants who makes the
Bold moves on her so if she's responding
stupid dude this guy's a genius loves it
when you gesture at her breast what the
[__] like she is the sexual Hunter
making the m
on you so you tell the girl for example
what are you doing to me girl why do you
keep looking what are you doing to me
girl oh bro I'm going to use this on
Tiff tonight my boy I'm about to stop
looking at me boobs or if you want to go
even more you reach out you grab her
breast you give it a light squeeze and
you take your hand away there's no way
there's no way work there's no way you
can make this gesture and talk about
honking boobs and be serious YouTube
can't allow that it's a bold move it's
bold move number three that's why that's
why that's why he said you have to show
confidence in entitlement when you do it
entitlement oh that's good when you're
dating a lady and you want to Honker tit
a commanding pres and you have to do two
bold moves first you're leading because
bold moves do not work ofself you're
nervous look guys if you want to grab
boobs you just go out you just got to go
out there and touch them you got to be a
confident boob toucher [__] about be a
p
dude these are all real man it's insane
dude for $24.95 you can he can teach
youx yo let's buy a let's all take his
course yo let's take his course man okay
so you're are you're ready to take this
seriously it's time to teach you how to
sneak up on a woman but confidently how
to kidnap a woman
safely this bu s [__] brush her boobs
go no what are you doing to me girl get
out of here bro that is not this guy by
the way that's this guy
yeah this is his website this is website
dude his sales copy is really
good he has a legit website about like
this whole thing that's a legit website
testimonials testim dude he looks like a
gay old man read he looks like a gay old
dude read the testimonials and see how
legit these are hey man my name is Sam
just wanted to thank you I've gotten two
lays so far and I landed three more
dates for this week hey good [__] for
you do another one do another one um met
a 20-year-old cutie at bowling pulled
her into conversation like you taught
date set for Saturday what the [__] is
that mean dude I'm a I'm a old man at 54
slept with 37-year-old 29-year-old and a
26-year-old thanks to Jesse I'm
happy this is bad bro I swiped the touch
on a big bll booby thanks
Jesse I got to honk on some nasty
Honkers earlier today thanks Jesse dude
it's crazy man it's it's um we got to
use his techniques there's dud
we got to do a followup with this guy
yeah this guy can come on J new anytime
you want Jesse please come I got some
questions my boy get to the bottom of
this man whoa we're kind of getting to
his that age bracket we want to get with
some young hotties some young hot
hotties yeah we're all old I didn't know
the keys were right in front of our face
the whole time yeah teach us keys are in
your pocket Nick hey that's the right
mentality
[Music]
n